I saw a guy was in like I like to keep
it somewhat adult when I fly I mean I'm
not wearing a suit or anything you got
to be comfortable but I saw a guy once
in the airport eating a sandwich wearing
pajamas and a bathrobe on and slippers
not as a bit either he's like it go to
hell Wow amazing that's like I'm flying
international that's alrighty digital
used to walk around and he would wear a
robe the jet ride he would always wear a
rope the only guy that can pull it off
though yeah it's wrong no one cared
right people think that like because
they're flying they should be
comfortable but they don't realize that
airports are known as the most populated
buildings
yeah never so this beautiful place where
everybody's going to see you respect
yourself right come on we're in a row
back you know you're you're a throwback
to the days when people used to you know
flying with an offense there is
something kind of cool about that but I
don't go that correctly you come to one
suit though I mean we admit suit I am
this is like you know a summer suit I
don't have to tell you this is yeah this
is all right
do you like dressing up if you it seems
like like you do your line of work would
not you know you don't get into comedy
and improv to wear suits right no you
know right like I like I like wearing
yeah like dressing I don't but also
takes so much time
like I tie the tie and pick out a pocket
square gosh right can you tie your tie I
can't I can't do it I've never learned
I've never learned to tie a tie shooting
something can we go up there soft I wear
a suit for that were suit jacket and you
got a [ __ ] I can't do the tiger ask
somebody tell my time I'm 49 years old I
can't come and look at are you all set
up on the Internet
oh yeah you're all set up oh boy am I on
the dark I think instructions for that I
yank I taught myself how to type
multiple knots now I can't do it yeah I
feel not yeah jumping Windsor not to
brag but I've actually very nice your
tie looks very good well done and the
top button is open so it looks
comfortable yeah yeah new year I should
have like Financial Times under my arm
right hustle and bustle you look like
hustle and bustle you're on your way to
work once you get to the office comedy
to young hustle on business
yeah I don't I don't like wearing them
unless I have to and I like I can't wear
a belt when I fly I can't wear pants a
button when I fly cookies I piss a lot
so it makes it uncomfortable it's on my
bladder
yeah I usually like I do the like just
circus Li unbutton my top button put you
know another notch on the belt right I'm
gonna be sitting down for a while yeah
and I don't take my shoes off though
like really second I sit down an angle I
know I understand my feet don't stink
I bet you they smell great they did
actually not bad yet you know what I'll
give you that one there's not better be
again yeah over there Bob Bobby Big Al
good would you say uh I would say they
smell pretty good together they're clean
then III I'm pretty hygienic hold on
Bobby's gonna sit down do you know Rob
you know Bob Kelly is Rob Porter
what's up Bob yeah big fan yeah I say oh
man but once you're what you're I'm like
a series that people are like it's a
popular series is that part of it too
like you can't go on a plane anymore and
take your shoes off because now the guy
from ballers oh yeah I like Twitter
explode exactly
this guy's got bear I would by the way
bare feet I wouldn't I don't even like
I'd rather wear shoes in the shower and
they don't see in my toes man but um if
like they're people with holes in their
sock and like the big toes sticking out
and for that that like that my sets my
brain on fire like how I can't even I
can't handle that
it was just comfort discuss myself yeah
it's disgust but you're all your cruise
people are girl tell you when I was in
third grade nothing's wrong with my feet
but when I was in the third grade Mary
Claire who lived behind me said oh you
have lady feet oh and that's gonna give
you scarred
yeah done my wife's trauma me my lady
don't you genitals know a long time ago
she said you have thin fingers and it
literally bothered me still relationship
like I why because my best feature now
you know I'm the farthest end
tell me took care of that problem let
him do the sex no but yeah I like it
really did it affected me to this day at
both I tried to like make my do like
like turn stuff and open things so you
can like take their fingers I just read
your finger my little iron
ironworker hand get some calluses going
on there like my dad's ham silicon
neighbor the guy next door has big hands
and I feel like she's looking at them
sometimes yeah I should have had those
well yes your physical appearance I mean
you're on a show that's probably the guy
who's in the best shape in the country
he's doing alright so yeah he can't be
somebody's like no pressure on you to be
pain about how you look totally totally
people always ask me I feel like oh do
you always feel intimidated like you
feel bad not like oh come on man like no
I feel great if anything like this that
he's a monster like he's a mutant yeah
to make me how much the rock works like
he literally I've ever seen anybody work
more than him every time you you you you
see him tweeting or Instagram yeah some
new project it's some new video they're
two million people are watching
everything success everything read a
watch what are the hit and even that is
going to do all over see sure it is sure
there it is sure his own production
company and everything so you guys
season three of ballers premieres Sunday
July 23rd 10 o'clock on HBO it's hugely
successful yeah who do you play on it I
play a guy named Joe who is he's a he's
just kind of like the head of the show
like he's a maniac
you know and and and he's but he's kind
of got to be the adult sometimes you are
you with a rot you and the rock of
partners so yeah try to be the rock cats
right I'm like his second you know and
but it's the kind of guy like you know
that guy like we all have you may even
be this guy or have been that the guy
that can like drink all night long and
still go to work and look fresh as a
daisy that's the guy that I play okay
right you just hate him for being like
yeah resilient there are guys like that
too they go to bed 3:30 and 7 o'clock go
in the office and they're fine yeah
you'll never notice something wrong they
can do it are you a football fan I
started I watch the show I started
watching the show
the rock mmm and then I was like I don't
know if I'm gonna like to show him
another football fan but like I watch
I've seen every single episode yeah it's
not funny that like the rock like even
the most cynical comedian loves the rock
whatever ever met anybody that doesn't
like it when he's just a nice man yes
yes he exudes but he's he's he has comic
timing he does like his [ __ ] hole in
me and Patrice used to watch wrestling
just to watch the rock really be on the
phone until they're on Monday nights in
New York and not do spots stay home to
watch the rock just do his interviews
just so he could just did it of just the
promos here so his promos was so funny
really cuz he's the right he had a good
writer but he was dead he yeah one of
the funniest guys out there yeah it's
throwing t-shirts over the interviewers
faces because they were too ugly yeah
yeah but it was his t-shirt a kiddy
shirt and he just drape it over his face
so just just bring it is so funny so did
you get off at the role did you audition
for it I got I got a meeting you know
it's kind of like a half an audition
here so I just met with them and I just
talked about football the whole time
oh it is yeah did you meet with a rock
no no Steve Levinson and you know so
funny we met at this place and his dad
shows up let big Lev Papa Dave we call
him and he's like Steve Levinson's
father Steve Levin's is huge Hollywood
producer right he shows up with his dad
like this 80 85 year old guy and he kind
of like looks me up and down and then he
goes to the bar and then I have a
meeting it goes great and I find out
later that he brings his dad to every
meeting like this to size because his
dad can size up a person right I think
that was WOW I like I don't know yeah
he's psychic or something what do you
think about you he's like well I got
that part
he's like this guy's not horrible I
guess right okay that's a monster what's
insane about show business altogether
that like you can prepare and figure out
like what do they want I'm gonna be the
guy and it comes down to like well my
operative my dad got a bad vibe and
we're not gonna we're not gonna do it
the other he just likes traveling with
his dad he's still too great I found a
great way to build it into the [ __ ]
budget yeah right
are you just offer only now or UO you do
some addition um you know I know I'm
definitely I like I I'm good at audition
oh you are yes so I'm totally willing to
a lot of things are just offers but I am
on the first guy to say like to ask for
the audition if I really want something
because because I'm good at it I think
it's the one to very harshly in the gym
very hard to I really yeah you had you
had I had to learn it when I first got
to New York because I was like that's
never taught you know you're never
taught out it's a totally different
thing because sometimes you you it's
just you a reader in the casting person
yet so unnatural which is and you're
never going to get I always get uh how
tall are you are you available yeah and
I'm like does that mean something it
means nothing means nothing
no that is asking everybody that's yeah
yeah I just like you got it yeah it's
never going to be that good like your
audition like it's not going to be
something that could like screen worthy
but you just got to do the best version
of whatever you're reading for that room
knowing it's an unnatural place and this
person's not an actor that's reading
with you and you know it's just it's
kind of fun and I'm in a weird way it's
kind of it's so weird that it makes me
laugh it is kind of hard you cause you
have to go in and that person you are
reading with just did starbucks orders
yeah yeah yeah that totally is like and
then is reading with you yeah and this
part could change your life it was funny
I yeah I had an audition a couple weeks
ago and the casting director was given
the reader notes the whole time more
energy more energy fun make it fun so
they always say that make it fun listen
[ __ ] writer does that I writers
should do it no more fun play yeah
exactly
finally hating I should get notes when
they don't give you notes have you ever
got an audition left and walked back in
and said could I do it again cuz you've
now you say no I'm psyched to get out of
there alright yeah yeah you just want it
to be over and I heard that once she
said no all right you asked for a second
try and she said no well actually two
times it's happened to me
one time it actually worked and I got
the part in the guy is frank lupo the
guy who invented the a-team and hunt
remember those shows yeah Stu Siegel
type of productions like on USA Network
or anything with you but and why went
went back in and I was like I listen I I
messed up I really I need to do that
again like I mustered up the did I need
to do that again she went no no way you
know you good yeah I was like okay [ __ ]
what I [ __ ] you know but you know who
did that name worked was John
Ratzenberger Ratzenberger burger that's
how he got a cliff on Cheers get out it
yeah he actually [ __ ] up boss the
audition and he went back in and just
redid it but he totally blew it the
first Wow maybe maybe sometimes they're
like you know what it's not going to
happen either way yeah they might just
don't you don't look right here I know
and a set like if ever I've cast
something you know in a second yeah no
no no right away yeah and then everybody
else who's not an actor the other
producers will be like I next guy I'm
like man sorry got to watch the whole
thing right like I just can't do it I
can't do it
my conscience oh you watch it well I
have to we can have two is you're on the
other side yeah yeah yeah have you seen
any bad ones
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just a
wrong idea and kids are really hard to
watch too
it's hard to watch kids audition why the
bed it's like everything's like a
Broadway musical or something they're
just like me I know and you can see
their parents off like you can imagine
their parents right off-camera like
mouthing the words you have somebody
famous like from a show that you're like
oh this is my I love this guy I love the
show and they come in and they just say
no now we just give offers for that [ __ ]
yeah I'm not going to like make whatever
Jon Hamm audition we had a guy from the
when we were doing the Bronx warrants
thing I was the only time I ever got to
be on the other side of it and I got to
be the guy I booked in the auditions and
they brought a guy from the wire end and
I was like eyes I know my cut this is I
was like this is John
I was like thank you for letting me get
this far and by this is and then he um
he made it she just made an actor choice
that was uncle he looked out the window
the whole time
and then at the last second turn and
gave the last line I see what he's doing
very Shakespearean and I was like what
perfect like that and it was just like
thanks yeah he's like this will be
ballsy oh yeah oh no they'll remember
the whole outside yeah alright well one
of those choices that you make where
it's like this is going to make a big
impact either way yeah yeah I decided to
not go for a maybe if I want to be hard
yes or hard no I had a commercial
audition and I had you know they they
like give you all the props for
commercials so I had a backpack on it
was heavy and so it was for an Affleck
commercial and I'm like walking up a
mountain and I made this huge choice at
the top I'm going to take my backpack
off and throw it off the mountain
so the second the backpack leaves my
fingers everybody there's like 15 people
in the room they go you know I was like
boy and it fell with like this crack and
I started to giggle a little bit like
who let this happen
I go what's in that backpack and the
writer goes that was my laptop oh don't
give a [ __ ] actor your laptop be on
set everyone didn't get so I did not go
forever I would have bought a house okay
with you she left me in the back to [ __ ]
is that right all that stink yeah you
make a choices like no don't do a good
choice solid choice I stand by it
yeah right if that laptop hadn't been in
that bag sorry for you know wanting to
jazz up an a-flat commercial they
shouldn't be giving you a computer to
carry without telling you that's a kid's
mistake not yours
I can mime it too by the way I get as
much look look guys I mean not good
radio but you guys can tell right right
at home right now I'm looking at you and
I'm thinking of a backpack on that's at
commercial auditions are the worst
because they do have they make you
pantomime a lot and pantomiming is the
[ __ ] where I prefer it really prefer
yeah I don't want to get fused with all
these props everything like you know
basketball I remember I didn't know the
basketball and I don't how to dribble
with a basketball
nevermind pantomiming right and I just
forgot to dribble and one voice and they
kept going to keep dribbling kids over
cut I love it like I'll do if I'm
driving and I'm just miming like in an
audition I'll make it a stick get the
clutch and shift it that's funny like
what why are you doing that this is the
love scene I never - how far apart to
put my hands on on miming driving for
some reason when when we - [ __ ] truck
or a bus I think no one does that it's
like this closely it's your natural you
got to do that thing we just put one
hand on it right casually cool [ __ ]
what I like you all school series how
you do it tell you like ours right no
one trying to slip a she in Goodfellas
natural not Henry you do I was going to
ask you have an idea like something like
Hot Tub Time Machine for example did you
have any ideas that would resonate the
way it resonated mo no right no no no no
I mean they had Cusack in it so I
thought oh this will this will you know
make some money it didn't it kind of it
wasn't a bomb but it didn't do great and
then it was became one of those things
that like you know grew a time and
became kind of cult if that was a
surprise gotta move you go see it's the
movie you wait till you're in your house
yeah and then you watch it Kent
unfortunately is like the case with
comedies these days right unless it's a
huge thing unless it's a whatever it
won't Baywatch I was going to say but
that bomb like you can't do a comedy
i I don't go to see comedies in the
movie theater now I see like big
spectacle movies or you can't watch at
home like that we need that's the way a
giant screen yeah I don't need them for
a calmness I've never seen a calm going
and you see in a movie comedy movie at
the theater in the whole theater
laughing yeah yeah like what about Mary
I remember that movie and the whole
theater was [ __ ] crack it you know it
is it's I think it's a lost experience
you know yeah I don't think I've been to
see a comedy in a long time um
rapport with Seth Rogen is one of the
last comedies I think I went and saw in
theaters yeah I can't think of another
sets movie I saw the what did I see that
at home I don't remember you don't know
what we did the [ __ ] about the
grocery store that is a we watch that we
had to watch it at home with at home
okay yeah then I didn't go see that yes
I don't enjoy comedies they're like me
laughing yeah it's kind of like yeah you
boil your comic like you punch out I
punched out right now like go to you
know make me cry or scare me
yeah drama and watching a part that you
auditioned for and didn't guess you're
mouthing the lines of the fertilizer but
what but it's like a black woman that
got it you're like yeah yeah I had no
chance we should have known - and that
wasn't meant for me it was a judge there
we go Jane Lynch has played like two
parts I've auditioned oh really really
yeah go get oh yeah I've only seen that
one - is that Andrew Schultz got
something I auditioned for it was in
some series it was just a guy at a bar
the Amazon series with Giovanni Ribisi
maybe that was it yeah yeah I was here
like a small scene in the years like to
see me pee and that was it but it was
I've never seen that Sneaky Pete I
refused by watching fest title I think I
want it it's really pretty good
I want dick I want to express it going
that's an Amazon Amazon now Amazon
what's that about Kevin Bacon it's the
weirdest [ __ ] show I've ever seen
what is it about it's about I don't know
I not about one dick about that oh yeah
there's a couple this I think there are
T couple and they go to this town and
Kevin Bacon is this artist who has like
a community and he has people come there
and live and do I don't [ __ ] know
dude I want to really fell in this one I
real cuz I wanted to the comedy or drama
it's both it's like this weird Rama Dee
I love Kevin Bacon I love I just love
him yeah I love whatever he does I love
the following was one of my favorite
show he's great on TV what happens to
the following it it had got a on the
following left
oh no one no one watched it was a movie
about a serial killer and you can only
go so far with it they went through see
yeah you should catch em the likable
serial killer yeah Wow yeah they do in
the second season they became friends
rather than mother and then it's like
where you gonna go with my Jesus I'm so
weak Awards a serial killers and I meet
you I'm not you know only one man can
stop up yeah we got ahead because he
thinks like them yeah yeah there's
always some girl in a basement with she
has 20 minutes to live he rescues yeah I
just can't watch offense although they
said Tarantino's next movie is going to
be a Charles Manson movie I believe only
cuz Tarantino is doing it I am so
[ __ ] tired of Charles Manson
but he couldn't Tarantino is going to do
it is this about Sharon Tate more about
Sharon Tate yeah that I'll watch that'll
be whoa okay yeah that'll be cool I
think he's doing I like it Sarah
- and Hollywood that weird 70s like
dirty kind of yeah swinging everybody's
[ __ ] yeah yeah women have hairy bushes
yeah so much hair great yeah we get the
head in the pool oh my god head
everywhere I was tired of Manson
yeah I mean a lot of my main story's
been told how do a sleet's uh respond to
ballers oh they love it yeah yeah they
love it man
and now we change the shooting dates so
we can get more on we change it to after
the football season huh because you know
usually we'd only have to get guys that
are injured Veta you know you can only
catch Victor Cruz so much right but but
like so yeah they love it man it's it's
pretty wild
who do you have on this year who'd we
get on this year uh Terrell Suggs it's
going to be on he's a I don't know I'm
blanking
bunch of guys I'm shy too tall athletic
dudes but you are you rock do you are
you guys friends you like have you ever
hung out with him I've gone to his house
and chill no no no no and he's not that
kind of guy either like he sees it he's
got a family you know he doesn't he
doesn't know you don't it's so funny
like I I don't think I've hung out with
anybody I've worked with really like
your friends but your your friends from
work yeah kinda I mean
Children's Hospital those were all my
friends first so those guys all hang out
with
then you know hot tub maybe sometimes
those guys will see him have dinner or
something but I don't really hang out
have you a dinner with the rock um
vine another okay yeah yes no it was
like a um like a cast dinner never
shared like one of those prepackaged
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches by
craft services with the rocks especially
it eats by the way he's get like a tub
of just white chicken breast and rice
and it's a huge and eats at weird times
of the day but like everything is so
regimented I get the Calton hey what did
his trailer look like you must have seen
his I was trailer I know but I see
outside is insane which is massive leads
in it's so beautiful and he's actually
got a TV on the outside of his trailer
so his driver watches TV like there'll
be games playing on the outside of his
trailer Wow I think he's got another one
too that it is just a gym in there yes
I've heard yeah gym every try I don't
haven't seen that one but I don't think
it's next to his oh yeah he can't just
be running off to the gym in the middle
of a shoot right what have you guys
started with that he works out twice a
day does he really so today that's all
built into his contract that he has his
work out Tiger have you seen his legs
he's got a workout twice it yeah very
incredible I know I was at a Gold's Gym
I was on the preowned machine behind him
dying and he was on the treadmill in
front of me and I was just I just wanted
to go jump on one of his cab that is
nasty he's not a human he's like a
different with a jogger walking briskly
he was jogging risky what was he doing
like a six five five yeah I would I
would make a concerted effort to be
friends with the rocket um I just want
him we have a great relationship and we
get along really well and I consider him
a friend but I don't want to I don't
want to do anything to ruin that right
yeah just keep it cool man we're good
right here he wants to hang out I'm all
I'm all his but I'm not going to be like
hey hey like bouncing around I'm like a
little obvious what if he's telling his
friends I can't dude he doesn't want to
hang out Rob's aloof you all talk to me
yeah I can man although it would be
great for somebody that everybody loves
like the rock
think that you're a loser like that
makes you even cooler you drop this one
like me yeah weird vibes I tried to get
I made extra rice and children and he
doesn't ask for any I might be blowing
this relationship yeah what is your
trailer like a double banger yeah yeah
that's a little bang gobble van yeah a
double banger doesn't normal old love
the double bed they get new trailers now
though like you know they used to have
the star wagons
yeah those crappy they're like from the
70s
yeah they got now they have these like I
don't know these green trailers that are
kind of looks like a boutique hotel yeah
in them so that's nice
they don't have them over here yet they
don't not New York it's our wagons our
wagons yeah it hasn't it has a DVD
player still that doesn't work table
that never this is the only show by the
way I've worked on with the cable works
right a trailer are you actually in LA
you sure yes York Yeah right shoe no no
okay you live there full-time
yeah was that a choice for just because
I don't know it was cause of work and I
am I lived here for like 15 years and
you know they I was like be gonna drag
me out of here basically and but but if
the only way I'll move there as if it's
for something and then I did and then
that something got cancelled after six
episodes and the writer strike happened
what was that I was called the winner on
Fox it was uh yes
McFarland's first live-action yeah and
it was about a guy like in his 30s who's
best friend he's kind of like a shut-in
weirdo and his best friend is like a 13
year old boy and it's really funny but
then I think one episode in Fox was like
what the [ __ ] did we do this is a child
molester show pull the plug on this this
is horrible
that's what she yeah it was creepy and
you're married right yeah did your wife
want to move or no yeah she's fine she's
fine wherever she doesn't she's moved
around her whole life what did she do
she's a speech pathologist no interested
what was that helping people who are
[ __ ] up oh yeah I have like two who
like she teaches people how to swallow
again after after accidents you know
motorcycle accident [ __ ] Wow yeah it's
something man I used to go visit her at
work and it was it was a bummer
stroke victims and all that stuff she
chest stroke victims mostly accidents
mostly like car accidents or motorcycle
accidents you know really sad stuff
where it's the person's fault but now
look they don't deserve what's happened
to them necessarily like and it's just
heartbreaking man she's just like just
does it
people who like it's their own fault
acuity act the way the accident happened
yet whenever yeah yeah it's usually like
we she'll say yeah well he was doing
this he was doing that but but I mean
look he lives in a prison now basically
he can't move his face you ever see
those people had [ __ ] try to blow
their head of a shotgun but they live
well I always think with their tongues
and teeth and like the repair on the
inside of the mouth must suck so much
and you're seeing the repair job yeah
like can you even imagine what the yes a
speech pathology you probably see a lot
of unpleasant sight she like the I see
television she's had to sweep just
garbage out of people's mouths all that
I like mucus she's like black mucus I
don't know what you were talking about
yeah well yeah she wears gloves oh yeah
she's very neat no she sticks her some
people I also put the only play dentist
he shut his [ __ ] handing her mouth
she digs it we may be old school like in
an 18-minute seventies and I think ideas
work gloves that haven't he said they
did they definitely did well I don't
know if they did it I think no gym dr.
styler who is my doctor did not wear
gloves on dr. Brown you know why would
he I was young I could get pregnant the
other day I was trying to get that
joking sock I think my dentist used to
like press his dick up against me tuned
because you really always add is like
crotch like right on my shoulder oh no I
got old enough I was like this is not
this is not like more comfortable plan
to be for him whatever I love or no no
no no no it was just pressed against an
angle here okay I don't know it's weird
are you stole something French Bank Bank
later yeah started getting a bad vibe
from doctor bracket yeah he's dead I can
talk about that sure it's just a vibe
you're not saying he did anything no no
I didn't know that I know I mean I was
out a lot in there you know
wake up with your little young
eleven-year-old boys highest skill
smoking the thermometer kill them yeah
so did you uh did you ever stop seeing
him buddy or say I can't go this guy no
I just you know went to college okay now
if that was it lasted quite a while it
was a while I had a guy used to my sweat
suits from who's a barber yeah by sweat
- threw him in New Jersey and then he's
a big fat guy and he would always press
up against my arm when he cut my hair
but I always get a weird vibe like he's
being yeah you know that like happens
sometimes you know they like a position
they have to get yeah but I don't know
it's just like when I was like 15 or 16
I started noticing a pattern and I was
like poses on that choice you talk to
your friends about it and you're like uh
don't you hate it when a dentist like
rubs his dick on your shoulder that's
part of the u.s. exam right like what no
talking about my rule is if he doesn't
get high it's not bad is it hot hard
hard
all right get hard to be so it's also
insulting if it doesn't feel at all
right the matter with me yeah exactly I
can't get a dentist bit harsher on my
shoulders got blood running this come on
so that was your only experience with
somebody trying to be a little creepy
yeah that's not that bad
no it's not them